for when you bonk completely you kind of
just well everything just turns like
jelly like you can't really think
properly even your eyesight is a bit
sort of like that hazy sort of do just
when you're like super tired and then
your arms are like jelly obviously your
legs are just empty and you're trying to
like paddle away it's just nothing there
and it just obviously you're hungry
maybe it's only half an hour more even
ten minutes it can feel like a lifetime
because all you're thinking about then
is food and you know what you're gonna
eat or you ride and pasta fast-food
restaurant or something and you smell of
food yes
it seems like even like a little a
railway bridge or something could feel
like you know help do eyes at the time
but I remember the first time when I hit
the wall or bonk was when I was I was
just a kid like maybe fifteen sixteen
and doing one and one of my first long
rides was out in the valleys and there's
maybe three of us or similar age and
yeah completely just nothing left empty
and it had no money or anything we
stopped at a little corner shop and that
was back when freddo's were like 10 B or
something yeah I was just searching the
ground for like any money or ended up
just asking somebody if we could have
ten pence off them so we could go and
buy a little freddo chocolate bar and
yeah and I was definitely the first once
I was the last but um yeah yeah never
quite been that bad since I think
avoiding it is just trying to be
prepared all the time using products
that are designed for exercise so like
your science and sport products opposed
to just some random chocolate bar where
you're gonna you know a massive spike
and a massive drop-off as well
[Music]